so you somehow miraculously wrapped it
back to the very beginning
of when we were talking about the human
um the beauty of the human genome
so i think this is the right time unless
we want to go for
a six to eight hour conversation we're
gonna have to talk again but
i think for now to wrap it up um this is
the right time to talk about
the uh the biggest most ridiculous
question of all meaning of life
off mike you mentioned to me that you um
you had your 42nd birthday 40
second being a very special absurdly
special number
and you had to kind of
[Music]
uh get together with friends to discuss
the meaning of life so let me ask you
in your as a biologist as a computer
scientist
and as a human
what is the meaning of life i've been
asking this question
for a long time ever since my 42nd
birthday
but well before that in even planning
the meaning of life symposium
and symposium
means together posey actually means to
drink together so symposium is actually
a drinking party
[Laughter]
so can you actually elaborate about this
meaning of life that you put together
it's like the most genius idea i've ever
heard so
42 is obviously the answer to life the
universe and everything from the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
and uh as i was turning 42 i've had the
theme for every one of my birthdays when
i was turning 32
it's one zero zero zero zero zero in
binary
so i celebrated my hundred thousandth
binary binary birthday
and i had a theme of going back hundred
thousand years you know
let's dress something in the last
hundred thousand years anyway it was
we've i've always had these that's such
an interesting human being okay that's
awesome i've always had these sort of
uh sort of numerology um
related announcements for my for my
birthday party
so um what came out of that
um meaning of life symposium is that i
basically asked 42 of my colleagues 42
my friends 42 of my
you know collaborators to basically give
seven minute species
on the meaning of life each from their
perspective
and i really encourage you to go there
because it's
mind-boggling that every single person
said a different answer
every single person started with i don't
know what the meaning of life is
but and then give this beautifully
eloquently answer eloquent answer
and they were all different but they all
were consistent with each other and
mutually synergistic
and together forming a beautiful view of
what it means to be human in many ways
some people talked about the loss of
their loved one their life partner for
many many years
and how their life changed through that
some people talked about
the origin of life some people talked
about the difference between purpose
and meaning i'll you know maybe
quote one of the answers which is this
linguistics
professor friend of mine at harvard who
basically
said that she was gonna she's greek as
well
and she said i will give a very pythian
answer so pithia was the oracle
of delphi who would basically give these
very cryptic answers very short but
interpretable in many different ways
there was this whole set of priests
who were tasked with interpreting what
pethia had said
and very often you would not get a clean
interpretation but she said
i will be like pethi and give you a very
short and multiple interpretable answer
but unlike her
i will actually also give you three
interpretations
and she said the answer to the meaning
of life is become one
and the first interpretation is like a
child
become one year old with the excitement
of discovering everything about the
world
second interpretation in whatever you
take on
become one the first the best excel
drive yourself to perfection for every
one of your tasks
and become one when people
are separate become one come together
learn to understand each other damn
that's an answer
and one way to summarize this whole
meaning of life symposium
is that the very symposium was
illustrating
the quest for meaning which might itself
be
the meaning of life this constant quest
for something sublime something human
something intangible some you know
aspect of what defines us as a species
and as an individual
both the quest of me as a person through
my own
life but the meaning of life could also
be
the meaning of all of life what is the
whole point of life why
life why life itself because we've been
talking about the
history and evolution of life but we
haven't talked about
why life in the first place is life
inevitable is life
part of physics does life transcend
physics
but fighting by fighting against entropy
by compartmentalizing and increasing
concentrations rather than diluting away
is life um a distinct entity in the
universe
beyond the traditional very simple
physical rules that govern gravity
and you know electromagnetism and all of
these forces
is life another force is there a life
force is there a unique kind of set of
principles that emerge of course
built on top of the hardware of physics
but is it sort of a new layer of
software
or a new layer of a computer system so
that's at the level of
you know big questions there's another
aspect of
gratitude of basically
what i you know what i'd like to say is
during this pandemic i've basically
worked from 6 a.m until 7 00 p.m
every single day non-stop including
saturday and sunday
i've basically broken all boundaries of
where life personal life begins and work
life
you know ends and uh that
has been exhilarating for me just just
the intellectual pleasure that i get
from a day of exhaustion
where at the end of the day my brain is
hurting i'm telling my wife
wow i was useful today
and there's a certain
pleasure that comes from feeling useful
and there's a certain pleasure that
comes from feeling grateful
so i've written this little sort of
prayer
for my kids to say at bedtime every
night
where they basically say thank you god
for
all you have given me and give me the
strength
to give unto others with the same love
that you have given unto me
we as a species are so special
the only ones who worry about the
meaning of life
and maybe that's what makes us human
and what i like to say to my wife and to
my students during
this pandemic work extravaganza
is every now and then they ask me but
how do you do this and i'm like
i'm a workaholic i love this
this is me in the most unfiltered way
the ability to do something useful to
feel that my brain is being used
to interact with the smartest people on
the planet
day in day out and to help them discover
aspects of the human
genome of the human brain of human
disease and
the human condition that no one has seen
before
with data that we're capturing that
has never been observed and there's
another aspect
which is on the personal life many
people say oh i'm not gonna have kids
why bother
i can tell you as a father
they're missing half the picture if not
the whole picture
teaching my kids about my view of the
world
and watching through their eyes the
naivete with which they start
and the sophistication with which they
end up
the understanding that they have of not
just the natural world around them but
of me too
the unfiltered criticism
that you get from your own children
that knows no bounds
of honesty and i've grown
components of my heart that i didn't
know i had
until you sense that fragility
that vulnerability of the children
that immense love and passion
the unfiltered egoism
that we as adults learn how to hide so
much better
it's just this back of emotions
that tell me about the raw materials
that make a human being
and how these raw materials can be
arranged with more sophistication that
we learn through life
to become truly human adults
but there's something so beautiful about
seeing that progression between them
the complexity of the language growing
as more neural connections are formed
to to to realize that the hardware is
getting rearranged
as their software is getting implemented
on that hardware
that their frontal cortex continues to
grow for another 10 years
there's neuronal connections they're
continuing to form new neurons that
actually get
replicated and formed and it's it's just
incredible that we have this not just
you grow the hardware for 30 years and
you feed it all of the knowledge no
no the knowledge is fed throughout and
is shaping these neural connections as
they're forming
so seeing that transformation from
either your own blood
or from an adopted child is the most
beautiful thing you can do as a human
being
and it completes you it completes that
path that journey
the create life oh sure that's at
conception that's easy
but create human life to add the human
part
that takes decades of compassion
of sharing of love and of anger
and of impatience and patience
and as a parent
i think i've become a very different
kind of teacher
because again i'm a professor my first
role is to bring
adult human beings into a you know more
mature level of adulthood
where they learn not just to do science
but they learn
the process of discovery and the process
of collaboration the process of
sharing the process of conveying the
knowledge of
encapsulating something incredibly
complex and and sort of giving it up
in sort of bite-sized chunks that the
rest of humanity can appreciate
i tell my students all the time if you
you know
like when an apple fall when when a tree
falls in the forest and no one's there
to listen has it really fallen
the same way you do this awesome
research if you write an impenetrable
paper that no one will understand
it's as if you never did the awesome
research so conveying of knowledge
conveying
this lateral transfer that i was talking
about at the very beginning
of sort of human humanity and sort of
the sharing of information
all of that has gotten so much more
rich by seeing human beings grow in my
own home
because that that makes me a better
parent and that makes me a better
teacher
and a better mentor to the nurturing
of my adult children which are my
research group
first of all beautifully put connects
beautifully to the vertical and the
horizontal
inheritance of ideas that we've talked
about at the very beginning
i don't think there's a better way to
end it uh on this poetic
and powerful note uh manolas thank you
so much for talking there's a huge honor
we have to talk again
about the origin of life about uh
epigenetics epigenomics and uh
some of the incredible research you're
doing truly an honor thanks so much for
talking
thank you such a pleasure it's such a
pleasure i mean your questions are
outstanding i've had such a blast here
i can't wait to be back awesome
you